there are so many people in this world
on the left and the right
who don't accept that somebody can is
entitled to hold a different opinion to
them
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry from
our brand new studio in central london
i'm francis foster i'm constantin kissen
and this
is a show for you if you want honest
conversations
with fascinating people our fascinating
guest today
is who laughs at the idea of being
fascinating as he's introduced
is the broadcaster and returning guest
to trigonometry and there welcome back
no pressure then they've got to be
fascinating okay i'll do my best
you are fascinating and we just have to
reveal it
as we have before you've just written a
book which is absolutely fantastic
and dare say extremely timely given some
of the things that have been happening
which is called why can't we all get
along
shout less listen more you see you even
got the title wrong you missed out the
word just
which everybody does funny enough i was
on bbc radio cambridge here and they did
the same
well i'm almost as good as the bbc what
can i say
no no bbc radio cambridge yes fair
enough
uh i'm almost as bad as a regional radio
station anyway
why can't we all just get along it's a
great book
we really enjoyed reading it but the
title itself let's talk about that
why can't we get along it seems like for
the last four years certainly and
probably before then i'm sure you'd
argue
we've just been suffering some sort of
collective hysteria delusion whatever
you describe it where
the fever pitch of our public discourse
has just
taken off i think one thing that has
become apparent is that there are so
many people in this world
on the left and the right who don't
accept that somebody can
is entitled to hold a different opinion
to them
and i argue in the book that unless you
understand that somebody is not only
entitled to have an opinion
but you know from time to time they may
be right how can you marshal your own
arguments
against them because otherwise you're
just talking to people who agree with
you
and that is really boring i mean my
radio show um
i prefer people to bring in to argue
with me not in a bad way but just have a
good debate
how boring would it be if i spent three
hours every night just talking to people
that agreed with me or thought i was
fantastic i mean wonders for my ego
but it would be very boring radio there
are radio presenters who
thrive on that who just want people who
agree with them they have a narrative
they want to get that narrative over
and anyone else who disagrees with them
is
immediately sort of cast into outer
darkness now
that's not what i think debate should be
all about
but let's not pretend that it's just
over the last four years this has
happened
i think this this if you go back to the
i don't know 18th 19th centuries you
look at the political cartoons at the
time and
and there were really violent debates in
the house of commons
and our current house of commons is
fairly calm compared to that
but i think what's happened certainly
over the last 20 years is
the the internet has intervened now in
many ways for good
the internet has allowed people to have
a voice and everyone should be able to
have a voice
but the destructive voices have come to
the fore i think particularly in the
last 10 years with the advent of social
media
back in the early 2000s i was one of the
first people to do a political blog
and i thought this that blogging as soon
as i discovered blogs i thought this is
fantastic
i don't have to bring up my website
person to change my website when i want
to put something new on it
i can do it myself in a few minutes now
that was great because it gave ordinary
people
a platform it might be that they only
had 30 readers in their local area well
so what it still gave them a bigger
voice than they had before
and i think blogging allowed people to
put forward views that were
different from what they were reading in
their newspapers or hearing on the radio
but with the advent of twitter i think
things have really changed and
twitter is a great thing in many ways
but it's so
spontaneous you can react instantly now
that's sometimes a good thing but very
often it's a bad thing
if i tweet to you that you're a [ __ ]
your instinct
your instant human reaction is to think
no i'm not i'm going to call him a
effing [ __ ]
so you type it instantly now on a blog
you'd probably
take a couple of minutes to think about
that and by the time the couple of
minutes were over
you think oh well i better not do that
that's a bit rude well on twitter people
don't think that
there's no buffer on twitter and it
it's not i think it's actually just sort
of natural human reaction
if we're attacked we fight back if you
look at the
way that politics works on twitter if a
conservative politician
is in a scandal or something the
conservative tribes sort of
um circle the wagons and defend their
man or woman
same on the left if corbyn's under a
tattle was under attack
he would be defended in the same way so
it's like my country right or wrong
there's no shades of grey here and
if you've read the book you'll know the
word that i most often use in the book
is nuance there is no nuance on social
media it's all black and white
and you're either for me or against me
you're in my tribe or you're not and if
you're not
then you're my enemy that's not how
public discourse
should really be conducted i don't think
and and don't you think part of the
problem is when it comes to social media
is that
we because of the nature of social media
it tends to promote posts that have the
highest level of interaction which tend
to be
lo and behold the most divisive ones
you know all brexiteers a racist all
remainers awoke or
whatever it may be so actually these
nuance points they simply don't get
promoted because of the algorithms no
and it actually
when you have people on both sides of
the brexit debate for example
who don't i mean i've never called a
remain supporter a ramona
i mean i just think it's quite
disrespectful
i might call them undemocratic sometimes
if they
didn't accept the referendum result i
think that's entirely
legitimate but i think if you indulge in
sort of calling people ramona's all
brexit [ __ ] or
or whatever i mean
is that really where we want to be in
our society
it's so pure that like so you see the
fact that people when i
i went i once asked a news night
producer when i used to go on news night
literally every week that it seemed at
one period
and even i was getting bored of myself
on news night and i said to one of the
producers i said
why do you keep booking me why don't you
find other people
and they said well we see you as the
thinking person's brexiteer
i thought well i've been called worse
but because i was seen as a sort of more
moderate voice than the likes of andrew
bridgen or john redwood or whoever
um and i was actually willing to
entertain the thought that
um that there might be issues with
brexit i wasn't sort of saying it's all
going to the land is going to be flowing
with milk and honey
but that enrages the other side even
more because they see somebody on their
television screens or they hear somebody
on the radio
that can put a reasonable sounding
argument for brexit and it destroys
their narrative that everyone on the
brexit side of the argument
should basically be cancelled because
they're mad or racist or
whatever and no i mean
isn't part of the problem and this is a
very coarse way of putting it
in that's unlike you i
but isn't part of the problem on social
media that you don't have the threat of
physical violence because when
you know if you're talking to someone
are you advocating for physical violence
it's i'm saying it's a deterrent it
isn't a terror man it's getting punched
in the face
i mean it's a modulator of behavior
let's put that one six foot two
like you're on west ham supporters yeah
i mean this is the thing i sometimes say
to people who insult me
on twitter you'd never say that to my
face yeah and they think oh come on big
boy
i thought yeah
but but i guess france's point is it's
maybe more
of a car situation where you're in your
car
and you feel like there's a safe
distance between you and another person
so you can give them all the
the finger salutes of different shapes
and sizes when
if you were standing next to them in a
queue or something you would never in a
million years i wish i thought that
analogy because i'd put that in the book
i'm helping you improve just sewing
little scenes just little seeds here
um but i mean we've talked about social
media to death and there's no question
that's been a contributing factor
but one of the things that you talk a
lot
about in the book is your industry which
is the media
and and you say in the 18th 19th century
similar things existed uh and and i'm
sure you're right
but i certainly feel like in my lifetime
which is not all that long
the the didn't say not as long as yours
no
the the the sort of way that
we talk about things has changed it
absolutely has
and i think we've seen this during the
coronavirus pandemic where you had
on the in these daily downing street
press conferences you'd have all of
these big name
journalists asking questions to the
various politicians
and generally they were questions that
were along the lines of
aren't you ashamed of yourself why don't
you resign you effing idiot obviously i
didn't put it that way
and so if any fool could have seen that
this was going to happen and on the 13th
of march you said this but now you're
saying that
and i think the public saw through that
because all they were doing was looking
for gotcha moments
they weren't looking to get information
from the politician or an explanation
all they were trying to do
was to get the politician to say
something that would give them the
headline
in the news bulletins and you see this
where um and this is
all broadcasters are guilty of this so
they ask
um questions which are that they just
pick their own journalist questions to
the exclusion of others even though they
may have been better questions
and got more newsworthy answers and then
at the end of the
press conferences you'd have all of the
regional and local journalists asking
questions
and they were the ones that were
actually spot on and actually got
interesting answers from the politicians
well what a surprise that
is in in a way the way the media has
developed
it's inevitable that this has happened
where if you're doing
three or four minute interviews so on a
breakfast show where inevitably it's
much more pacey than
at other times of the day and the
politician goes into the
studio with maybe one or two things that
they're determined to say whatever the
question is
and the journalist starts off not with a
sort of
softball first question because you
haven't got time for that on a breakfast
show
you go straight in why are you lying to
me minister well immediately the
shutters go up
but if i start with a if you started
here with an aggressive question to me
immediately my defenses go up and i'm
probably not going to say anything very
interesting you might think i haven't
anyway
but i mean it's just again natural human
nature
and so i'm really pleased actually
that's
the long-form interview is coming back
particularly on podcasts where you don't
have a time limit
i mean your show is all an hour long the
podcast i do sometimes
um maybe two hours long we just go and
see how it goes
um and you actually i did a 78 minute
interview with andrea leadsom the other
day
now many of your viewers think oh my god
i bet that was interesting
well actually it really was and i had so
many people say my god i saw a different
side to her
i really like her now which i've never
seen that in her before
and i mean our job is not to make
politicians interesting they've got to
make themselves interesting
but if you can bring things out of
people in that kind of format that's
so much more satisfying i think than
just trying to get
some crappy newsline out of someone and
embarrass them but don't you think the
problem is ian and that
a lot of the mainstream media they're
finding impossible to monetize
they're really struggling financially
this is the only way that they can make
themselves seem relevant in many ways
well it may be but it's going to be a
short-term pleasure yeah
and in the long term they will just eat
themselves i mean
we've seen that this week that there are
now apparently
two rival news channels being
launched because well presumably because
they think that sky news and the bbc
aren't doing a good enough job now
commercially i'm not sure i see how that
can work
back in 2006 i was part of a team that
launched an internet
tv channel called 18 downto street and
it was i mean a bit like this
we we did live programming but also
recorded programming where there was
much longer you had a lot more time and
it was seen i remember a lot of people
wrote it up and saw some new
fox news because we were predominantly
on the right although we had
people like peter tatchell presenting
programs it wasn't entirely on the right
um now that was ten years ahead of its
time
and it only lasted a year but it i mean
that cost
i think it cost about a million pounds
over the course of that year this is not
a cheap thing to do
so although i i think competition is
great and i'd love to see a whole
plethora of different style of news
channels
um that is a reaction to i think a
widespread feeling that
mainstream media news channels in a way
aren't servicing
their public properly um now a lot of
the times you've got people on
the i won't say far right but people on
the right people on the left
who think that the bbc and skye
are either right wing or left-wing and
then the bbc and scott i think oh
if they both think that we're either
right or left we must be doing something
right which is the laziest way of
thinking i think
and it's interesting that tim davey the
new bbc director general
has already in his first week stepped
into this and said well
i think we are getting things wrong
we're not speaking to the whole country
in the way that we should be
we're good on him and i i let's see what
he actually does
we're recording this just after it's
been announced that they've reversed the
decision on the proms and there will be
singing now
in a way not a massively important issue
but
that i'm sure will have come from him
and that is a signal
that something is going to change at the
bbc i
i hope he's right because i think the
bbc is a bit like an oil tanker it's
quite difficult to turn around
but let's wish him luck i think the
symbolism of it is quite important
because we've obviously gone through a
period of time where
a lot of people feel like british
history as a whole thing has been under
attack
yeah and to see that the national
broadcaster sort of spearheading that
movement it's not what a lot of people
and the the other interesting thing here
is that the the left have tried to
pretend that this wasn't a story that it
was got up by the right
well i was listening to the fortunately
podcast which
with jane garvey and feed lovers one of
my favorite podcasts i mean they are
artists i don't i regard you as a bit
above a podcast because you do it all on
video too
so well i wasn't lumping good answer
[Laughter]
um and they had nazarene malek the
guardian yeah and they were talking
about this
and she alleged that this whole story
had been fabricated by the right
um to enable boris johnson to look
patriotic and all the rest of it
well the journalist who broke this story
in the sunday times
is grant tucker who used to be my pa so
i spoke to him i mean when the story
happened i thought well that is a really
good story
and so i talked to him about how he got
the story so what the sort image didn't
tell me
necessarily who the sources were but he
actually had quoted name sources as well
i'm thinking well how can you say this
wasn't a legitimate news story
so she's accused him of fabricating it
which i think is a really serious
allegation to make
it wasn't a fabricated story you can say
well um it's a stupid story because who
who who wants to sing all these
old-fashioned lyrics anyway fine have
that debate
but it's a legitimate story to write
have you ever been abroad and felt out
of place because you didn't speak the
language
no because i voted brexit brexit means
brexit
i know that when you go on holiday
sometimes you don't speak the language
it can feel really awkward
a little bit like francis talking to a
woman do you want to learn another
language
now i don't for obvious reasons but if
you do
then babel is quite simply one of the
finest apps to use to achieve your goal
it is it's got amazing simple to use
interface they've got daily 10 to 15
minute lessons that you can do
that have been proven effective in many
studies as a great way to learn one of
14
languages that they offer so it doesn't
matter if you've got struggle with
language
for a variety of different reasons maybe
you find it tough or maybe you're just
english
right now babel is offering trigonometry
fans
six months completely free all you've
got to do is head over there get the six
month subscription
and use our special code which is of
course trigger
go to babble dot co dot uk
play and use the promo code trigger on
your six month subscription
that's b-a-b-b-e-l dot co
dot uk forward slash play and use the
code
trigger and we're not going to explain
how to spell the word trigger
because that would be patronizing you
you mentioned this
sort of new right of center channel
potentially that people are talking
about
and i thought you you said you didn't
think it was going to work do you not
think there's a huge gap in the market
there well i haven't said i don't think
it's going to work i think it's going to
be difficult for it to work commercially
now there are lots of people with very
deep pockets who might be willing to
accept that it's never going to make a
profit and that they'll happily
subsidize it
i think it can work from a journalistic
point of view
i think you can have a channel which
has uh which allows opinion i mean i
work for a channel where all the
presenters are encouraged
to express their opinions and we have a
very diverse range of opinions
at one stage it went from sort of nigel
farage through to ken livingstone
i mean actually they weren't on at the
same time but um
i think that is the way probably to do
it
rather than have just a whole stream of
uh
right of center presenters who are
inevitably going to
give i mean it will inevitably call the
british fox news if you do it that way
i'm not sure i would want to watch a
channel that did that necessarily
because
why would you just want to watch people
that you might
agree with all the time i think you've
got to be challenged
and otherwise you just develop lazy
thinking habits
and isn't this a problem that if we do
have this channel that it's just going
to increase polarization
and that people who agree with it are
just going to watch it and they're not
going to engage well we can see what's
happening in the united states where if
you're on the right you watch fox news
if you're not on the right you watch cnn
or
msnbc i'm not sure that's very healthy
for
anyone really but that's what that's
where the point you made about the bbc
is so important as you say
that the mooting of this new right of
center thing
is a direct response to people a lot of
people feeling that the bbc has gone
to the left and and so if the bbc under
this new director general can recover
a sense of what their role is which is
to provide balance
and uh unbiased reporting if they can
achieve that
which remains to be seen at this point
then then
then that threat of a right of center
channel may dissipate by itself
potentially it could do and the bbc is
capable of doing that
if you think backed and people forget
this if you think back to the brexit
referendum campaign
i thought they covered it really well i
think most people did it was only
afterwards when all the shenanigans
started that
you could tell that there weren't very
many brexiteers
working in the bbc and that is that is a
problem
and the fact that they didn't really see
all the sort of red wall thing
coming up to be fair i'm not sure
anybody saw it to that extent a lot of
our guests did
well they okay well fair enough but yeah
sorry
i mean i i certainly thought that would
be a tory majority i didn't think it
would be
that much um people like matt goodwin
paul embry
that that sort of caliber of person that
we've had on the show repeatedly
they all predicted it with quite a lot
of confidence because they were aware of
what was happening
uh and uh the metropolitan centrism of
uh
sort of broadcasters in general i think
was probably a big factor in that there
were two things first of all
i don't think the bbc or anybody in the
sort of
london media bubble understands that
boris johnson has an appeal outside the
m25
and i was saying this i've always said
this if you walk down the street with
boris jones it doesn't matter whether
it's in kensington or halifax
he attracts people around him in a way
that no other politician does people
want to have their selfie i mean
he is a he's he's got it whatever it is
he's got it in spades
and i've never seen that in a any other
politician with a possible exception to
margaret thatcher what about you and
duncan smith
[Laughter]
and that's the thing i mean ian duncan
smith once said that
you have 90 days as a political party
leader to make your mark
yeah if you haven't made your mark after
90 days you might as well give up there
and then
and i think he's absolutely right now
you can't create charisma
you either have it or you don't and one
of you does and one of you don't doesn't
i'm sorry
but it's it's true you cannot people see
through it
yeah sometimes people try too hard i'll
give you an example
um liz truss i think tries a bit too
hard in this regard with her
sort of instagram photos and they're
amusing but i'm not sure they did her
any good as a sort of creditable
politician she didn't actually add to
her
political credibility um by doing all of
that stuff
um people people want when cameron had
this phrase keep it real
and you've got to keep it real if people
don't like your personality
you're not probably going to persuade
them to you know before france has asked
me a question
just on david cameron my wife is
completely political you've met my wife
i think
possibly briefly maybe you haven't but
anyway she's completely apolitical
couldn't care less about politics
at all but she said she said to me
she's not right or left or anything like
that but she said to me every time i see
david cameron on tv i want to throw up
he just looks so dishonest really yeah
yeah that was her
i can think of many politicians i could
say that about but he wouldn't be one of
them that's interesting
she just thought he was a sort of very
fake person but anyway speaking of i'm
interviewing him
uh in a couple of weeks that explains
that i'll put that to him
put that to him why why are you so fake
but speaking of prime ministers uh prime
ministers who've been criticized
boris johnson is someone who during the
hustings in the last election you you
you had
a little bit of a run-in with his fans
it's fair to say and that's what i have
always liked about you is
you know you are probably center-right
on some issues
center-left on others but you are on the
right i think
i would self-describe as being on the
center right center right
but when you nancy is how we do yes yes
yeah exactly
with a few sort of lefty social issue
right yeah uh so for example in
immigration you described just what is
what is a letter exactly so but when you
were interviewing boris johnson you
actually pushed him quite hard to to
the chagrin of his following at the time
what do you make of boris johnson's nine
months or wherever it's been
in in power so far believe it or not
it's over a year now
wait wasn't it december 24th no right of
course yeah
yeah of course wow yes yeah um
my next book which is coming out in
november is a history of prime ministers
because in april 2021 it's the 300th
anniversary of the office of prime
minister
so i've commissioned 55 people to write
an essay on each prime minister
for this book and i've written the boris
johnson chapter oh wow
um and i mean i've written it up to the
end of april i might do a little
it's going to print soon so i can't do
much of an update
um i said before boris johnson became
prime minister that i thought he would
be one of
our great prime ministers or the
shittest prime minister we've ever had
now it's far too early to come to a
judgment
now i think he did what a lot of people
thought would be impossible he has got
us out of the european union which
i was beginning to doubt whether that
was actually going to happen
so that's certainly on the plus side
which i mean i would say that wouldn't i
if he gets a free trade deal done of any
in any meaningful form with the eu by
the end of the year
that will be a significant achievement i
actually do believe that that will
happen
um we already know that there's we're
about to sign one with japan which we're
told is actually better than the deal
that the eu has got with japan i think
that would be a landmark uh
thing to do if we've got a lot of the
free trade deals rolled over from the eu
by the end of december
again an achievement but
he's not going to go down in history as
the brexit prime minister which is what
he thought he would he's going to go
down in history as the coveted prime
minister
and i don't think even his greatest
fan could say that he's got a stellar
track record in handling this
statistics don't lie in the end
and although i think the british public
are very forgiving
um there are things that were done over
the last
four or five months that could have been
done differently could have been done
more quickly
and it's easy for anybody to say in
hindsight oh you should have done that
you should have done that
but there were people for example on
lockdown there were plenty of people
saying this should be done a week or ten
days earlier than it was
um and i think that would have been that
that was the main
error that was made um the fact that he
was out of action for
or a month six weeks the fact that i
think he's still suffering from the
after effects of that
and i think this is leading to
speculation that i mean if he does
get the free trade deal and say the
economy has
gone back to a semblance of normality by
the middle of next year
it's entirely possible that he might
think well i've done what i came to do
i quite fancy the thought of earning
millions of pounds a b for being an
ex-prime minister
i don't think he's enjoying it as much
as he maybe thought he would
i mean how can you enjoy being prime
minister at this kind of time
it's not like being in a war
although people make the war analogies
it's not like fighting
a war and i i just get the feeling that
it's not
the job that he thought he was going to
be doing
um and so it wouldn't surprise me if by
the end of 2021
his dominic cummings father-in-law i
think was suggesting that he might go
before christmas i can't really see that
but it wouldn't surprise me at all if by
the end of 2021
he thought or maybe into 2022 he thought
okay i've done what i came for
um let's get someone else a chance now
it's unusual for a prime minister to
give up office voluntarily
but boris is an unusual politician so
nothing nothing would surprise me
i don't think he's done overall as bad a
job as his critics would necessarily say
um but i i think if you were marking him
it would be
quite hard to go above a b minus and
that's probably being kind
and in there's quite a few people who
said that he was
quite weak during the uh black lives
matter protests he wasn't particularly
visible
and when you know the statue of church
was being defaced he should have taken a
stronger position
upheld you know law and order do you
agree with that
i think it's really difficult for a
conservative politician on those
issues because whatever you say is going
to be taken down in evidence and used
against you
i think things were mishandled in some
of those i mean to my mind
the protest shouldn't have ever gone
ahead anyway given
that we were right in the middle of the
serious part of the pandemic
and all social distancing rules just
were ignored
interesting that this week of course and
it will be a few weeks by the time this
goes out but
pierce corbin uh fined ten thousand
pounds for breaking
the better corbin the pedicle
but but i mean he did the same thing as
the blm protest he went out and
organized and participated in a public
protest i think the the difficulty here
and i found this when all this was going
on and i was covering it on the radio
every night i knew that one word out of
place
if i if i'd sort of made any derogatory
mark about remark about what was going
on
i mean that that would have been a
really serious thing i mean it was
it was if you're a politician or a
broadcaster on those things
you are one word away from losing your
job or ending up on the front page of
one of the tabloids
um and i was very careful to try and
distinguish between the black lives
matter
movement and the black lives matter
organization as we were yeah
but that gets lost in translation
and i i don't know if you saw i i had a
call one night from a woman called
denise in enfield
and she took me to task for what i was
saying and so that i was looking at it
through that my white middle-class prism
which i took
the exception to and we had quite a bit
of a ding-dong about this
and then i i'd sort of let her talk and
she was then saying well of course what
you don't get
is the black people we don't get the
same chances
that white people do and i said no i do
understand that
and she said there's a black woman it's
even worse
and then she's saying of course on your
radio station you've only got one female
presenter you've got no black presenters
at all i said well
imagine noah's is not black but he's an
asian muslim
and we have she just signed rachel
johnson so we got two and then
and then she said yeah and i wonder how
she got the job
and i said well she didn't just walk
through the door and come into a studio
and brought
she's actually been she's about four
years i know that she's been doing
auditions and
she wasn't just offered a job for the
fact that she's the prime minister's
sister
she actually had to prove that she could
do it because but again that's got
nothing to do with skin color
no it hasn't but she said i wouldn't get
through your front door and i thought to
myself do you know what you're right
so i said okay come and present the
program with me tomorrow because there
was something about her that i thought
and and we ended the program and i i'd
i was thinking all the time i was saying
this because i said don't you think i've
made these points to the management here
that we need to
up our game in on this i said i have
done and i
as i was saying i thought i'm probably
gone a bit too far here
and i said at the end of the
conversation um well if i lose my job
um if i'm not here tomorrow denise it's
going to be your fault which is all can
i have your job
she's been coming in for an hour every
week or every fortnight since then
now we're not going to give her a job
just because of that
and just because she's a black female
she's got to prove that she can do the
job because believe it or not
sitting behind a microphone for three
hours a night is not just sitting there
and having a little chat with somebody
you've got five things going on in your
head at any one time
you've got to be able to handle a
breaking news story a terror attack
and not go to pieces you've got to be
able to handle mh17 being shot down over
ukraine
and that's the only thing that you know
you go into rolling news mode
and that's the only piece of information
you've got and your task is to keep
people listening
but not bore them to tears just by
repeating the fact
you've got to talk to experts on it
you've got to actually have an
understanding well what
i mean how does a plane get shot out of
the air at some twenty thousand i can
tell you all about it
i mean people think that i must be sort
of like a pagan [ __ ] just sitting there
doing what i love doing talking
but you're you're constantly thinking
right i'm interviewing the cabinet
minister next what's my first question
i'm talking to somebody my producer's
talking in my ear
all sorts of things are going on and at
the end of the three hours you are
mentally exhausted
you're physically exhausted sometimes
depending on what kind of program you've
done
um so you can't just sort of give
anybody a job just because they think
they can do it but
and i do i have talked to enough people
on the radio over the last 10 years
of black heritage of asian heritage to
know
that there is discrimination whether
it's conscious or subconscious
there is if your name is you are less
likely to get a job interview than if
your name
is francis that is just a fact there's
no point in us
denying it it is a fact and that has to
be addressed
and we're not being fair to people if it
isn't addressed i don't think we're a
nation of racists there are racists
among us we all know that
but i do think there is there is a
degree of subconscious racism in a lot
of people people who
don't like to think that there is it's a
sort of i'm not a racist but
kind of syndrome so i have a lot of
sympathy with some of the aims
of the people who were demonstrating in
some ways
but i can't support a movement that
wants to defund or abolish the police
depending on who you talk to or abolish
capitalism i'm sorry i'm not going to
say that i can support that organization
and one of my regrets is that
when this was all happening right in the
first week
um we had uh a minute silence for george
floyd on lbc or on all of the global
radio stations
and i was given a statement to read out
um after this which in retrospect
i think i should have said well i want
to amend this because
it didn't wholly reflect my views yeah i
was the one i was the messenger
and what was that discrepancy i can't
remember the exact details but i do
remember at the time thinking well
should i sort of challenge this but the
problem is it was being read out on
every other global radio station
but what was the gist of it is what i'm
getting well i think it was about the
organization
as well as the the the general aims
um so he was sort of being asked to
declare your support for the
organization
well it was it was me on behalf of the
whole organization
right and it was i just i think in the
end came to the conclusion that it
probably wasn't worth the fight
but i mean that that was also not long
after uh
nigel farage left and it sort of played
into this narrative that developed on
twitter that sort of had gone awoke and
all the rest of it
um so looking back possibly i should
have
done that a little differently and we
talk about the death of nuance and you
said that you know broadcasters not just
yourself everybody in the industry had
to tread
very very carefully when it came to
discussing the black lives matter
organization
and if you made one misstep you'd be
cancelled why is that
why do you think it is that we've come
to this point where you can't make a
legitimate criticism
of an organization without you well i
think i can now
but i think it would have been very
difficult to do that
when it was all going on um i did
i mean i did say that i thought that
statues shouldn't be pulled down
all the rest of it i didn't think that
was a particularly controversial thing
to say but others did
um and i did fear where that would end
because i thought that it may well be
that
over the whole country you might get
statues being
taken down i mean there were people
wanting to take this churchill statue
down
where where does this end charles smalls
got a really good piece in the spectator
uh today well or maybe it's last week
where he's talking about camera the
guy's name but somebody
who the british museum have now hidden
away
and he went through what this this is
somebody from the 1600s
um what he had achieved but he had
married somebody
who was the daughter of a slave owner
i think and it was sort of guilt by
association
and charles was saying well i mean if if
really that is where we're heading and
this
why would anyone donate money to the
british museum if they think that
they're going to
sort of be trashed in 300 years i mean
it's
it is a very dangerous path that we've
gone down
here and i'm glad that it was just that
one statue that
came down um and i'm sure there are i
mean it is a difficult one
just from a moral point of view um
i'm sure there are people in germany who
think that statues of hitler should
still be allowed
to stand where do you draw the line
everybody's going to have a different
place where they draw that line
and um i think the issue on the statue
was
from certainly for me i don't know
whether this was the case for you but
for me it was
not so much the statue itself it was the
method by which it was taken down
if the people of bristol had
democratically voted to remove it
uh great i mean the people of bristol
are entitled to have any statue they
want or don't want
but just randomly walking up to a statue
that you personally dislike
and pulling it down with a mob i don't
think that's how it should be i mean
you know my ancestors suffered from the
the the policies implemented
following karl marx's work there's a
statue of marx in london do i
get francis and anton we go and pull
that down well that's what's not
competent you're going to need someone
you could you could probably handle
gandhi though because i mean gandhi was
a racist
yeah absolutely so but of course nobody
well very few people would suggest that
the statue of gandhi and parliament
square
there were a few people on twitter well
maybe there were there always there
on twitter but it's very difficult to be
consistent
on this but my worst fears weren't
realized on that
i mean the demonstrations that happened
in london i thought were
generally well handled
there was violence in a couple of them
but there always are because they
generally get hijacked by the the usual
suspects
and though i think the one in whitehall
uh i think it was the second one i mean
that was on a different scale
yeah when police forces were attacked
and all the rest of it
um but it's still we're still at a point
where it's actually still not really
socially acceptable to question
anything on this and that's not a
healthy state of
debate and what about you you bring up
the
the particular riot and with the horses
being attacked policewoman being knocked
off a horse hitting her head
i mean i personally to me that looked
like a riot that particular one
and it was reported by the bbc as being
largely peaceful
and that was something that a lot of
people picked up on well if you
it was largely peaceful i mean most of
it i mean if you if you if you divided
up the time
you could well the world too was largely
peaceful by that by that sort of way
because most of the time soldiers
weren't fighting
they were sleeping they were eating they
were sitting around playing catching it
a bit but on a six-hour demonstration
there was probably about an hour at the
end where it got a bit
hairy um i mean i'm not defending it i i
i if i was a bbc executive i could
happily defend
describing it in that way but
um i think they were a little bit
not just them though i think sky were
exactly the same
they were quite reluctant to give the
full
picture of what what actually went on
there well the reason i bring it up is
at the moment cnn i don't know if you've
seen these i've been i've i've shared a
couple of them on my twitter
uh where there's a guy standing in front
of a burning city going
uh peaceful demonstrations bl you know
all this sort of stuff
and it does seem to me potentially that
the fear that you are talking about or
the concern
uh that one ought not to
criticize this thing one or
to be extra careful means that people
are
hesitant to report reality now maybe the
reality
is maybe you're right that uh they were
mostly peaceful
but but that isn't how we report riots i
mean if
or or violent demonstrations that have a
measure of violence
if for example brexiteers had gone on a
march or a protest
in which 27 police officers were injured
i don't think that would have been
reported as being largely peaceful
no no i think you're right um
i think part of the problem here it's
difficult to know what to believe when
you see pictures
from demonstrations protests riots
whatever
how do you particularly on twitter how
do you know that it's actually from that
particular one they've been so many
examples and
there was one last week i think where it
purported to be from a particular event
and it turned out it was from something
two years ago and this is where the fake
news thing
really comes in because um
i mean i've retweeted a couple of things
and
i've just found out afterwards well that
wasn't what
actually happened so then you apologize
and delet
i mean i was i don't like deleting
things on twitter because it looks as if
you're trying to step up taking away
responsibility from yourself
but you because if you explain well
actually i'm sorry i tweeted that
because that wasn't what it was
people don't see that bit they just
still see the original bit so it's
always a very difficult decision as to
whether to delete or not
no i mean that is the problem isn't it
when it comes to something like twitter
when you retweet something that you
believe in you turns out
it's not what it initially appears but
do you think we're in a very worrying
situation at the moment ian with
public discourse because i'll be honest
with you i'm i'm quite worried about it
yes i think we are um and
the only the only kind of negative
comment i've seen on twitch about my
book is somebody's saying well yeah
you've diagnosed all the problems
and but you haven't really come up with
that many solutions
and i said well did you actually get to
the end of the book because i've got 50
ways there's a list of we're going to
improve public discourse now if i'm
honest in retrospect should i have
included those
within the narrative i don't know but i
think
in the end it is us as individuals that
are going to be able to change this or
not i know i've moderated my behavior on
twitter where i mean i
i would get involved in ridiculous
twitter spats and someone once said
oh intel's such a nice guy on the radio
but on twitter he's an absolute beast
and they were right so i mean i've tried
to change that because i'm not
an absolute beast i could mix it up with
anybody
i can if i have to have a really loud
debate with somebody i'll i'll do it
but i think we just have to try and calm
down
moderate our behavior and just try and
be a little bit nicer to each other i
know this sounds like sort of kumbaya
and
sort of hugger hoodie and all the rest
of it but
in the end i mean we're going to end up
in a very very dark place soon if we're
not careful
and how far along the path do you think
we've gone and
do you think we can turn back i'd like
to think we can
um
[Laughter]
well sometimes it takes something big to
uh really make people sit up and think
about what they're doing
and i think it does put responsibility
on people
in the public eye a little bit where and
people do tend to take their i mean
everybody
has heroes and role models and all the
rest of it and if they see their hero or
role model acting in a particularly
bad way then they're more likely to
imitate it and i do think also
and i i don't know i have put this in
the book but i do think schools have a
role to play here
in teaching kids how to handle social
media
and maybe they do it i don't know i'm
not i haven't they don't
no well they ought to because i mean
they do teach about safeguarding i know
that
but this is more than safeguarding this
is this is almost what
when i was in school we would have had a
couple of hours each week a sort of
general studies lesson
where you civics is what it used to be
called
and that's i think where teachers
need to actually teach people about the
art of public discourse and how to
debate
and i'm not sure there's enough of that
going on in our education system at the
moment
no well no absolutely not and certainly
but we talk about the art of debate i
don't think politicians have got the art
of debate
in many cases you see the way they
interact with each other you look at
question time now
i mean what is question time but just a
series of people
talking over one another as you know
yourself
well it is um
i mean i find i did any questions
last week and it it's an oasis of calm
compared to the television
version and the last time i was on which
was a year ago now
um i mean i nearly walked off the set
because i was just so disgusted at what
was going on and
um if i had done i mean it would have
created such a massive
storm and i'm glad i didn't i did do it
on good morning britain
um a few months afterwards because i was
in the middle of
a pincer movement from two people on the
left and i thought
you know i've got better things to do
than waste my time i
i listened to grace blakely for um about
a minute and a half saying what she had
to say
i then got nine seconds out before she
interrupted me
and then the guy to my left interrupted
me as well and i went to speak again and
then they started i thought sod this
regame of soldiers
and i mean as i was getting up i thought
oh should i do this
but i'd have absolutely no regrets about
it because i think it did
it it drew a line in the sand certainly
for me
so i'm just not going to put up with
this level
of impoliteness and rudeness and
what was the feedback like on that
including from the producers themselves
very interesting um i mean i had to
as soon as i because i literally walked
into the green room got my coat got my
bag walked out to the car
and i i was i was furious and i people
say i flounced out i did in that show i
was very calm i walked out
but i was very angry and the producer
sort of
ran after me as i got to the car i'm
really sorry really sorry
and i said well these things happen but
and if you don't want to come on the
program again quite understand but i'm
just not putting up with that oh no no
don't worry don't worry
and um the two presenters texted me
afterwards say really sorry we should
have stepped in but we didn't
um and i then spent
three hours driving to norfolk didn't
look at twitter i did put out a tweet
saying well
i i can't remember what i said but sort
of the hashtag kill pierce morgan
thus far and no further and um
90 of the tweets were supportive
even people who don't agree with me
politically
but then what i've worked out is that
whenever i'm in the headlines for that
kind of reason or any reason
the way the left think they can get at
me is to retweet the video of me
on brighton seafront in 2013 when
well according to their narrative i beat
up a pensioner
it doesn't sound very good doesn't it
um what actually happened and i'd go
into exhaustive detail in the book on
this
because i don't i don't hide away from
it um i actually
pulled the protester by his rucksack
straps away
he then tried to punch me missed the
momentum of that sort of
made us fall over but according to them
i wrestled him to the ground
you will find no evidence anywhere of me
punching him
kicking him doing anything apart from
trying to restrain him from getting into
the tv picture
uh because my author damien mcbride was
being interviewed
um but the left have edited this video
to make it look far worse than it was
so they just retweet this video whenever
i'm in the headlines that's what they do
even though it's seven years ago
and so i just blocked them i mean i
really couldn't give a monkey's
ass how many times they do it because i
know what happened
most normal people can see what happened
and
um yeah but going back to the incident
at good morning britain don't you find
their apologies a little bit
disingenuous because let's be fair
they engineer that they create that
atmosphere
that's what they want so then you get
the clips which go again when we talked
about in the beginning
shut up i want to get back in good
morning britain i've done it like four
times
you've done it you've done it enough now
you see i
i totally get why you say that and i
think there is an element of that in
most of these types of programs
um but i do every friday morning
at 6 30 a.m with jackie smith former
labour home secretary and we do the for
the many podcasts together
which people like because we do get on
and even though we come from different
political angles
we have a laugh we in 210 episodes we've
never
fallen out um we analyzed the week's
news
and it's all very good natured and we we
do it on good morning britain
as well and the viewers really like it
you don't i don't think people at 6 30
people don't want to barney do they i
mean i don't really watch breakfast
television but i mean i if i did i don't
think that's what i'd want at 6 30 in
the morning every time they get me on
that's exactly what they wanted
this is what i was gonna ask you about
that do you think that
they apologize and we're getting into
the weeds but i think there's a bigger
point
that goes beyond that particular
incident which is more about the media
in general
which is they apologize to you because
you made a stand
and it became clear that a line had been
crossed but if you just sat there and
took it like a good little boy
they wouldn't have even noticed that
something had occurred
well maybe i mean look i i'm in their
position
so i you know because you come on my
cross question program sometimes
i mean sometimes you do have to step in
and say what
i mean david starkey um who has been on
the show
several times i mean he kind of knows
that he goes on these shows and a
performance is expected of him and the
other three guests who are on the show
i don't know have you been on with him
no no the other three guests on the show
know that effectively it's the david
starkey show
and on each occasion i have had to pull
him up for something
that he's done or said which won't come
as any surprise to
anybody i mean i can't remember what it
was last time but it was
it was quite a sort of misogynistic
thing that he said and we had
a very sort of feminist left-wing woman
on
and it was quite offensive and and i
just
and i just said david you cannot say
that you just cannot say that judging by
his face it was quite funny
please apologize to be fair to him he
did
you know the the great thing about david
stark is that um
he he just is gold dust in terms of
engaging
even if you hate him you kind of you
want to watch it
there's one time we were talking about
um
there was some story about pornography i
can't know what it was
and he gave a very erudite answer to it
and i was about to move on to the next
person
and i just saw him lean into the
microphone saying
but of course ian as you know i love a
bit of pornography
i thought oh god
you know he's very funny david we had
david on the show
prior to the whole yeah darren grimes
thing
and actually on our show he didn't say
anything out of line at all
um he was very entertaining i mean he's
obviously darren grimes is a much better
interview
obviously he managed to get him to say
something super offensive
but that actually that speaks to again a
broader issue which is
what do you do now because we're so
quick to judge people and to cancel them
obviously
on your show you just pull people up and
you say look you shouldn't say that or
that's inappropriate or whatever
but what what do we do with with with
someone like that who makes
you know who's a great historian a
fantastic man in many ways but in some
ways goes too far
or says things that might have been
acceptable 50 years ago when he was
growing up but aren't now
how do we handle that as as as a so i
got caught up in this because
i had seen um darren grimes i think had
tweeted that they were raising money
for his reasons project and i like
darren i think he's a good guy
sometimes can be very naive i think he
would admit that himself
um so i went on the crowdfunding page
and put 100 pounds on thought nothing
more of it
and then 10 minutes later somebody
tweeted
i can't believe ian dale is supporting
this after what
david starkey said on this interview
because i hadn't even seen this
interview i didn't even know it existed
but it had been on the internet for a
couple of hours but i just hadn't seen
it
so i watched it and i thought oh my god
and i thought well darren you really
should have challenged that but he
didn't challenge it
and i think i mean darren himself said
that starkey's always been one of his
heroes and i completely get that and i
think there was a degree of being a
little bit starstruck there
um and i was like
really getting serious dog's abuse for
this and i thought well i'm not gonna
sort of get the hundred pounds back i
think actually darren grimes is a good
guy
it's a reasonable project and um
but i had to in the end i thought well
i've got to condemn what david said
so i did um
and i thought i'm never going to be able
to have him on my show again because of
this
but i have do you still feel that way no
i don't that's interesting
so what was it i think what changed it
was
david's apology now to me it was a bit
too late he should have
immediately done it but it was two or
three days after after a couple of
organizations had basically disowned him
and um david is actually a fundamentally
kind person
very kind yeah and um i remember
interviewing him at edinburgh last year
and he was
i think he's the only one to get a
standing ovation at the end and bear in
mind as you all know
both edinburgh audiences are not exactly
right-wing audiences
but he was very emotional very personal
and talked about his partner's death and
all the rest of it
and i mean i like to think i have a
reputation of standing my people when
they're
going through difficult times and i mean
david sent me
um an email after reading what i'd said
and
he was i think he was quite upset that i
had said what i'd said
and i said well look you said it you've
got to own it you've got to take
responsibility and
you can't expect people to rush to your
defense for something as
awful as that um
and anyway i
am going i'm having lunch with him in a
couple of weeks
and um i want him to come back on the
program at some point because i don't
believe in
uh cancelling people for
uh i mean it was it was an awful thing
to say and i'm not trying to
minimize it and i'm sure if he does come
back on the program i'm going to get a
lot of abuse for that
while my shoulders are broad enough
[Music]
so it was the apology that changed it
for you
yes if he hadn't apologized i don't
think that i could have
justified but i'm curious because for
there were some people who were like
well
he just made a mistake or something well
he did make a mistake but it was a
mistake that was
i mean okay it was he was
likes to exaggerate to make a point yes
and that was
i mean okay that's not a sin to do that
but it was just that the way he did it
it was the timing of it as well
that nobody could defend it yeah and i
think in the end he absolutely realized
that no no my point
i don't think he did sure no i agree
with you my point is for some people
there are some people like you did
nothing wrong there are also people for
whom it was so egregious in their minds
that you don't come back from it the
apology doesn't cut it
like yeah he apologized as you say a
little bit late
but you know he's racist that's it done
does that bury him now sort of thing
well i
don't belong to that school of thought
in this case i'm sure there
might be other cases i mean if if
somebody in a similar interview had said
uh i don't believe the holocaust
happened i don't believe
any jews died in the holocaust i'm sorry
never want to have anything to do with
you again
um i i don't think that this was on that
scale
and i'm not i'm not minimizing it it was
a terrible thing to say
um but in the end somewhere you have to
draw a line
and do you think broadcasters positions
have become more precarious over the
years or do you think you've always been
treading a fine line as a board
you're always treading a fine line not
just on these issues
um if you are if there's a terror attack
and you're going into rolling news mode
there is a line of speculation which you
can't really
go over even if you are sure that it is
a particular group that
did this you until you've got some sort
of evidence you can't do it
and i have seen broadcasters cross that
line in the past because they've got
nothing else to say they've only got
something to speculate on and that
as i say is when you really earn your
money and i'm not a trained journalist
i'm not a trained broadcaster
but in the end i've got to rely on sort
of 30 or 40 years of experience of
knowing what you can do and what you
can't do
and so far i haven't sort of stepped
over
over that line and the parameters of
what you can do and what you can't do
have they become
narrower over the years in terms of what
in terms of what is acceptable what
isn't acceptable what is acceptable to
say and what isn't acceptable to say
i think that i mean we are governed by
ofcom rules on
certainly on words that you can use and
that you can't use i think there's been
a
little bit more leniency on on that side
but if you take the example of mental
health i do a lot of programs on mental
health issues
and there are words that 10 years ago
would have been quite acceptable to say
on the radio
which aren't now um and i don't think
it's
it's not just political correctness here
it's actually just common decency
in the i mean if you think about it we
all
use the word nutter or for somebody
who's got
mental health issues that actually is is
a really
horrible word to use i remember pulling
up nick clegg for using it once
live on air um
and i explained why it wasn't a word
that we should really use in
polite society and he's oh no i quite
understand
and then the next day i saw him use it
in another interview the same way
and you might think well that's being
totally oversensitive
but you you do have words have
consequences
and although i i'm not going to say any
words should necessarily be banned i
think the offcom rules on most swear
words for example are utterly ridiculous
in that i can't say bollocks on the
radio but i can say grollocks
and everyone knows what i mean when i
and i do i do that
and you can't use the word [ __ ] anymore
even to describe a female dog
i i don't know the answer to that you
want to call someone with a [ __ ] to say
they're a female
i can't say that oh well before i came
here i heard concert in bitching about
francis
if i do that the producer presses the
dump button it's outrageous
and they did that to me not that long
ago
and i said don't you ever do that again
i said if i was calling
a female politician a [ __ ] on there
absolutely
never i never would but if i did that
fine but
not when you're using it in in that kind
of context it's utterly ridiculous
um but we we have also seen examples
there was that
quite well known example of the radio
producer or the radio presenter who got
temporarily lost their job then
reinstated
because they doubted the existence of
white privilege or they criticized it to
go on manx radio
yeah yeah well see to me that is that is
a debating point
right i mean i think it's unquestionable
that that
uh particularly white males
do even if they can't
bring themselves to admit it do get
white privilege i i do think that there
is a case for that
but to actually question it doesn't mean
say you should lose your job
and you've got it in the bbc where ian
lee lost his job as a breakfast
presenter on three counties radio
for um arguing with a woman caller
who was basically saying she was a
devout fundamentalist christian type who
was saying terrible things about
homosexuals
so ian lee took her to task for it and
called her a bigot now if i'd done that
on lbc my boss would praise me for doing
it
he got the sack for it
that's really interesting well yeah and
on that note
before we ask you our last question
perhaps you know
why can't we all just get along
you've you've given a list at the end of
the book of 50 things
but what do you think you know you said
that we as individuals have to solve
this problem
so if we as individuals were to do one
or two things
each to really start to to
dial back the rhetoric to to start to be
able to have
conversations and good faith again what
would we be doing well i think two
things one of which i've already really
covered but one would be
to calm down take your time reflect a
bit before you respond to anybody
where you feel the sap rising just
stop for a few seconds and think do i
really want to say this do i really want
to get into this
fight um and second of all
i think just to try to accept that
somebody else is entitled to have a
different opinion try to understand
their opinion
try and understand where they're coming
from with it try and understand why they
argue what they do because as i said
before if you if you don't try to
understand
how can you argue against them apart
from just saying you're wrong
i don't care what you say you're wrong
well you need to articulate an argument
you can't just get away with just saying
you're wrong or you're a [ __ ] or
whatever um
even if it's true
[Laughter]
you might say that so i mean
there's no this is not rocket science i
mean this is um
i mean it was actually comparatively
easy to come up with 50 ways i always
hate these things when people do lists
29 ways couldn't you think of the 30th
one
but yeah i could have gone on to 100 i
suppose but in the end you have to stop
somewhere but i think you're right
really it's about a sort of
self-discipline yeah
about restricting yourself from your
inner demons taking over and running a
mock
um yes it is and look i'm not a saint on
this i have tried
i've i mean i was on jeremy vine the
other day with gemma forte
and she was basically saying that
boris johnson was terrible he got this
wrong he got that wrong
and any fool could have worked out that
that wasn't going to i said
hang on a minute why don't you actually
stand for election
you happily come up with all this
criticism
but and i probably went over the top a
little bit in my tone
and what i have to accept as a 58 year
old white male
no no i am 58 i know it's difficult as a
58 year old white male when you argue
with a woman
on television it's not a good look if
you even
look as if you might be slightly losing
your temper yeah
um and i mean i have to do panels now
where there's two or three women
and i just generally then sit there
smile sweetly and speak when i've spoken
to
because i know what it looks like if you
get involved in a
in a sort of feisty debate which if it
was three other men
you wouldn't hesitate in doing but
that's the world we live in nowadays
constantin's russian he doesn't have any
of those
that's why they bring me on good morning
britain just shouted
[Laughter]
very very prudent uh yeah it only works
in hot liquids apparently
it's so racist in hot liquids do you
know that does it really yeah yeah
i don't drink chilled coffee so i'm safe
you are safe uh
but we have as always one final question
for you
which is what's the one thing we're not
talking about as a society that we
really should be
uh west ham's prospects for next season
would be one
absolutely but i'm gonna
i'm going to introduce something now
which you might find a little bit
uncomfortable
um in the book i wrote right about a
time that i was nearly raped
and i didn't really think anything about
writing this
because it it didn't traumatize me at
the time and it doesn't traumatize me
now
um but the observer rang me up and said
they they were doing an article
on a tv series called i will destroy you
there's a male rape scene in that
so they said can we do an interview with
you about this so
i spent about half an hour on the phone
to them and the
article wasn't about that at all it was
just about me
which was a bit of a shock in a way um
so i then did a phone in on lbc the
following night for two hours
and the number of men that phoned in
say yeah this happened to me or either
happened to me or nearly happened to me
or my mate or whatever and i do think
this is something
that society doesn't really talk about
we've got a lot we've had a lot of
taboos in society and this is kind of
one of the last ones i think
twelve thousand men were raped last year
um
i think only about a thousand of the
cases ever got to court i don't know how
many
um actually were convicted uh
the average how long do you think it
takes
for a man who has been a victim of a
sexual assault whether it's
by and often it's actually a straight
male that is
doing it um really yeah how long
does it take for a man to tell anybody
about it
on average i'm going to guess like 20
years 26 years yeah
wow now you think of the mental health
aspect where somebody is bottling up
inside
and i know several people that this has
happened to
just in my sort of circle of contacts
and i think well if i know
sort of there's probably four or five
what about the ones that i don't know
and you think well this
this is something that needs to be
addressed and
um there's a charity called survivors uk
which i've now kind of adopted and sort
of if i give money to charity they they
get it because i think this is a really
big issue
that i mean people don't want to talk
about for obvious reasons it's a very
uncomfortable subject
but it's also i mean there's also and
again
i've i've the day one of the national
newspaper
commissioned me then to write a long
read feature on it which in the end they
decided not to run
which i was a bit annoyed about because
i spent a lot of time writing it
researching it so i've actually put it
on my website now
um and i i just think
that it's something that people
need to understand that it happens and
it's not just men on men it's actually
women on men as well bizarrely
i mean okay it's slightly more difficult
for a woman to rape a man
but there is a lot of um i mean if we
just think of the sort of me too things
about some
male employers groping female staff or
making inappropriate comments to them
um i remember back in the 1990s where
i was um i mean
a woman that i worked with just grabbed
my
crotch now imagine if i as a man did
that to a woman
that didn't traumatize me at all i just
said do you think that's appropriate
um when she was northern ireland
secretary at a labour party conference
she had a picture taken with me and my
partner we were running the bookstore
and she stood in the middle of us
put her arms around us and started
kneading our buttocks
that's sexual assault again
i didn't i thought it was quite funny at
the time but in today's environment
you can't call it anything else so
there's so many issues around this that
i think we shy away from talking about
so that's very long way to answer to
your question no but it's a very good
answer and
uh if anyone i'm sure there will be
people in our audience who unfortunately
have had
this sort of experience survivors
survivors uk survivors uk should they i
mean have a read the article it's on
iandale.com
and i mean i literally had dozens of
people contacting me on twitter about it
and saying well
i thought i was the only one and you can
understand why well
the uk's most prolific rapist was
actually a man who wrote
men absolutely right well that's a nice
way to end
yeah it is cheery as ever yeah
cheerios everybody and thank you so much
for coming i enjoyed it thank you for
having me
it's a pleasure to have you back i
recommend everybody gets the book why
can't we all
just get along uh it's fantastic read
it's an audio book as well
in your voice i read the whole thing the
interesting thing is i've had a lot of
people who say they've read the physical
book but they can hear my voice
in every sentence which is actually the
biggest compliment they can pay me
unless i don't like my voice it is
really a great read because you've woven
your own story
into into into the way that you talk
about things but thank you for coming
back
uh thank you for watching and we will
see you very soon with another brilliant
episode
or a live stream which all go out 7pm uk
time thank you very much guys and see
you soon
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the youtube channel
click the bell button next to subscribe
button so you get notified when a video
comes out
and follow us on all the social media at
trigger pod
and also leave us a nice review on
itunes and spread